okay I believe that the African African
countries will benefit from your world
football Cup because we know that there
are so many missiles tourney outside
African countries I think that this is a
good time for the African countries to
show their strength that they have that
ability to hold such magnificent you
went very important and then we attract
our attention from the outside the
African countries to pay attention to
the African continent and that to
realize the to see a real african
country and also it will raise the
people awareness after summer some
difficulties and some challenges and
some potential the huge potential
opportunities of the african countries I
think it's a good opportunity for
African countries to show their to show
them to the outside world thank you